had a recent question how often should
you do in a minute fasting well good
question
and there's several ways to do it and
let's just kind of go through the
different ways you have something called
the five and two which actually I do not
like it all five days of the week you
pretty much eat what you want and then
for two days maybe it's going to be on
the weekend you do a version of
intermittent fasting which is not in a
minute fasting is basically you reduce
your calories down to 500 calories per
day so that's kind of mimicking fasting
so here's the problem it takes three to
five days to adapt to ketosis so if
you're gonna eat what you want for five
days and then for two days go down to
500 calories you're gonna be so hungry
and craving I mean what are you trying
to achieve if you're trying to do weight
loss you're going to spike insulin on
these days and this is going to be so
insignificant so I do not recommend the
five and - then you have the every other
day fasting where you're not eating
anything for one day and then one day
you're eating back and forth again it's
going to be rough because it takes three
to five days to fully adapt to ketosis
to the point where you're like nearly a
hundred percent especially if you have
insulin resistance but the point is it
takes longer so every other day doesn't
allow you to do much adaptation so I
recommend you do daily in a minute
fasting so one of these right here you
have 16 and 8 which is probably the most
common
so you're fasting for 16 hours but
you're eating window is 8 hours so let's
say the time between your breakfast and
your dinner or your lunch and your
dinner is a total of 8 hours because
they don't really specify if you're
gonna do two meals or three meals but
you have an eight hour eating window but
then you have sixteen hours of fasting
for the average person this might be a
very good thing now the key is not
snacking of course and also what might
be good is if you were to do this with
two meals and then not eat anything else
but in the eating window so
have your first meal and then you wait 8
hours have the second meal and you have
nothing to eat so you're getting the
benefit of that fasting after the second
meal all the way to the first meal on
the next day and then you have 20 and
for which I really like this one because
you can start seeing even more benefits
especially with anti-aging and it's very
therapeutic for your brain and your
heart and it's for a lot of things it's
good for repair so let's say for example
your first meal is at 2:00 in the
afternoon and your second meal is at
6:00 that would be a 4-hour eating
window with 20 hours of fasting and
you're not eating anything during that
period of time you're drinking water you
can have coffee maybe a little cream you
can take your vitamins you do tea you
can probably also do things like stevia
but you're not having any meals because
an actual meal will trigger insulin so
this is a very very good one and then
you have ohm at one meal a day and a lot
of people are doing this with fantastic
success it's even better than this if
you can do it if you're over the age of
50 and you want to lose weight this is
probably what you want to shoot for as
you get into it and adapt to it because
not only are you gonna lose weight
pretty quick but if you have any type of
blood sugar issues
you're gonna fast for it what 23 hours
so it's a lot of so it's a lot of good
repair action now if you are a diabetic
and you have a slow metabolism and
you're postmenopausal I recommend doing
one meal a day every other day now I
would work up to that but some people
need to do that to see even more change
especially if they're not seeing a lot
of weight loss in their midsection and
they just need to take it to the next
level and with this - you can also add
periodic prolonged fasting so you're
fasting a little longer maybe every two
weeks or every month maybe you go for 48
hours or 72 hours that just puts the
icing on the cake maybe I shouldn't talk
about cake the key thing is always make
sure you're doing keto healthy keto
within a minute fasting because a lot of
times these programs allow you to eat
you know have a cheat meal
well ideally we don't want to do that
because it just kind of sets us back
there's alternative foods that you can
eat to give you a dessert or that you
eat with the meal not as a snack that
are very similar to some of the pleasure
foods out there so it's when you're
doing these right here every single day
you're really allowing your body to
adapt and get into it and so it's very
easy at that point because you're not
craving anything anymore so your hunger
is gone these other ones you know I
can't say that your hunger is gonna go
away from that
also you wanna look at the purpose for
doing it let's say you want to lose
weight well it really depends on your
metabolism if your metabolism is fast
then you can get away with somewhere in
here
okay maybe 18 and 6 if it's slow you're
gonna have to go to oh man or even one
meal a day every other day now if you're
doing it for health reasons let's say
you have Alzheimer's Parkinson's or
epilepsy or some other health problem I
think this would be perfect for you one
of the challenges that you may have if
you want to not lose as much weight is
that your insulin is gonna be so low so
you're gonna lose a lot of weight so you
may want to just eat large meals on
those two meals and make sure you add a
little more fat maybe keep your carbs at
60 grams okay a little bit higher than
what we normally recommend which is 2250
so I mean if you're like in your 20s you
can probably handle that going into in a
minute fasting this is what I recommend
start off with three meals a day you
might already be on that but you also
might be snacking so the first step is
to cut out the snacking okay especially
at night that's number one now if you
find that difficult just add some fat to
the meal okay then what happens is use
the rule don't eat unless you're hungry
okay in the morning am i hungry
let's say you're not then don't eat go
as long as possible
without eating okay so ideally the first
meal would be at the lunch time
okay but if you're still hungry in the
morning it could be the day before that
supper the day before you had too many
carbs okay that could be why or you may
need to add more fat to the meal or you
just have to give it more time or you
need to add some MCT oil to your coffee
here to allow you to go longer okay so
anyway when you do that you're gonna go
longer and long and longer so you let's
say you have your breakfast here and
then the next day it's here and here and
then finally you're here okay so then
you have two meals a day and then let's
say you want to go to one one mill a day
then you slowly start to eat later and
later later so you do one o'clock two
o'clock three o'clock that depending on
your hunger let your body tell you when
to eat adding fat when necessary and
then make sure that you're also doing
your nutrients - that will help cravings
as well and make it a lot easier alright
there you have it there's my answer to
how often you should do in a minute
fasting so if you want more knowledge on
how to create a healthy body subscribe
now and get daily notifications